I feel like no matter how hard I try,
my house is always a tip and let's be expected
given that children are messy and husbands are oblivious.
But we're about to walk into a long weekend from Matariki
here in altar on New Zealand
and there is absolutely no way
I'm celebrating Maori New Year in a messy house,
mainly cause I just like to relax and enjoy the festivities.
I mean, it's not gonna happen,
but dreams are free, right?
Matariki is super special in this country
because it signifies the start of the Maori New Year.
It's a time to reflect on the past,
celebrate the present and make plans for the future.
And personally, I love giving my home a big
deep clean prior to this
because it feels like it's really clearing out any old energy
and making space for what's to come.
But I tell you what,
the craziest shit always happens to us around this time of the year
and I swear it's because of Matsuriki's new beginnings.
By the way, I didn't have the time,
energy or the facts to give to iron my tablecloth,
so please don't be upset. Anyway,
so this time last year, we had just moved into this home,
took us a full nine months to sell our previous house and it was a lot.
But then one day actually on my son's birthday,
this house got listed
and it was going to auction on my brother's birthday
and I thought Wow, those dates seem synchronicitus
and somehow we managed to snag this absolute dream home
and it was a good reminder to trust the timing of your life.
Fast forward a year and a lot has happened.
There's been a lot of cleaning,
a lot of renovating, and a lot of really good quality family time spent.
And to me that is the thing that makes me happy.
And this is gonna sound super fucking corny,
but I don't even care. My only goal in life is to lead a happy one.
It's not how it looks, it's how it feels.
By the way, I fully intended to come on here and talk about my cleaning
as I do on all of my clean dogs,
but the Matariki Spur has got me.
So now we are reflecting. And on that note,
I actually have some tea to spill.
I've never said this publicly for safety,
but for the last 13 months,
my husband's been working almost three hours away
and spending most of the week away in another city.
And after I've spent so many long days
and even longer nights flying solo with the kids,
he's finally finished up with that role and I'm so happy
and I like to think we have Martin Icky Magic to thank for that.
For my other news,
I decided to push myself completely out of my comfort zone
and go on a reality TV show.
For some reason it's called the traders.
It was super challenging
and you can watch me struggle on TV three from July 1st.